hey guys I'm Ryan right this would be
crazy Veronica six toes and we're gonna
watch a trailer for the new spongebob
movie um let me see what it's called
real fast let me see what it's called
real fast ladies hold on ladies hold on
ladies hold on hold on for our lives
it's called the Spongebob movie sponge
out of water don't know anything about
it girls grow up on some I job I
actually didn't grow up on some punch
Bob so hard I got some movie that the
first movie the day it came out what now
that were men we can do Becky I lost my
brother
this is funniest cartoon back in the day
Phyllis I never actually uh grew up
watching spongebob because I didn't have
cable the war or the crime trial shape
or you know it's like sure there's
children in Africa but in America would
need a neck table years don't fit in
with the rest of the world
cut the [ __ ]
what's your [ __ ] problem Rock is
wearing my clothes because she had she
came over last night
and so did Alyssa and uh they they're
not fully made up right now because
there's Alice's birthday yesterday you
celebrated her 23rd birthday yeah so
they they crash here after a few drinks
drinks
Veronica stole my clothes if you know
what I mean oh [ __ ] oh no oh no we're
gonna watch a trailer now
he's much booked
wait where's near my hair's gonna pirate
but to harness his power
I need the final page that he's
protected deep below the surface by one
legendary hero
will you stop lying aren't you
overreacting isn't that your house save
their world
come on team let's get that book back
they must come to ours
oh that's so weird in 2050 motion
picture event this is uncomfortable huh
I'm so extreme now it's our turn to
rewrite the story you need new fans
those guys must work out I've been doing
my spin class
any good
maybe we should have picked a better
superpower for you Patrick Oh who's in
the pineapple under the sea
SpongeBob SquarePants are together for
sissies SpongeBob SquarePants
what does anybody know there are some
years to Marco's I don't know I didn't
grow watch me because I didn't have
cable Veronica doesn't understand you
get good as an understudy
oh there are people in Africa suffering
you don't understand sure there are
starving Mexicans in Africa you're right
anyway we shouldn't joke about that
sure we can no no we can yeah no this is
going in there not this is going in
there you girls are gonna look great
making fun of poverty yeah no oh yeah no
yeah sounds like assault right now no
yeah don't ya come on let me do it no no
no you should go you should go he'll be
flirting no it's not how are you sorry
awkward oh okay and don't you baby that
looks interesting looks interesting I
like the idea because you know they make
a lot of these animated live adaptation
movies where it's like Smurfs and it's
kind of weird because it's like live
adaptation yeah but this time they're
like no it's still the cartoon but we're
transitioning it into real life you know
so it still has a cartoon world about it
it's the same you know caste and stuff
so that's really exciting that's really
cool huh and then 20 wonderous is really
you know has a lot of range he's really
flying in a ladder in his acting career
yeah
I'm excited you guys I have to follow in
tradition anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and alyssa has her channel
ELISA be out of her [ __ ] mind
and Veronica has her Channel barrel love
92 is the URL Veronica six doses her
name alright guys well that's it for
today's episode kidding what do we do
next ladies you don't know that's the
[ __ ] that the zeny reviewer can
I get a shout out please he's a little
bit uppity what does he need a knee dude
check out this guy I feel like we're
gonna get along just fine
let me look she's so [ __ ] great yeah
listen be zany who currently has three
subscribers with four videos up okay he
is a movie critic um I'd say check out
this cute I'll subscribe to him you guys
I feel like he's gonna be good he
started young so the future to like each
video is gonna get better better he's
gonna build his craft yeah
build your craft and then ladies will
come the [ __ ] will come walking down
the street true mm-hmm mm-hmm
if anyone knows how to get [ __ ] it's
this guy I mean look oh I'm the king of
the world right now
wait where's that cat look at what cat
wait fail I fail at jokes
wait what explains you can't explain
your joke you must explain your chip
yeah
the zeny reviewer doesn't understand
your joke yeah Cat Cat anyway uh [ __ ]
yeah what cuz no he was referring so
much [ __ ] yeah okay oh hey yo this
video is just a lot of noise anyway
check up a senior reviewers Channel he's
a good twelve-year-old kid or something
like that and one day my friend you will
insert that pennis into a vaginal canal
juicy you Sally
Ryan where'd you get your legendary
t-shirt I got it from legendary pitchers
my friend mmm promotion to them and a
shout out will be nice too well Jewish
CL needs
she asked me Jesse his name starts with
you he's gonna be Jewish or Maggie what
about Julia you sell just only about
Juilliard yeah I like the Jewish idea
better are you Jewish dude I hope you
are I grew up in Catholic school so Jews
to me are very exotic creatures and you
or something I'm drawn to hello when you
laugh because you always get close to
people's faces anyway who Sully is
probably how it you actually say it like
the connect connects the correct
pronunciation well Jew Sully yeah my
legendary t-shirt I got it from
legendary pitchers because they saw my
legendary [ __ ] that's right ladies tell
them about my [ __ ] my [ __ ] she set it up
for me Oh play long first did you
comment now will come comment and you're
never like yes and that's the rule of
him from yes and Jesus that's not what I
was aiming for anyways don't even don't
laughs what I was aiming for what
because they you joke with the cat come
on like we were substantial where's that
cat all right guys well this has been
today's episode tune in next week where
Veronica and I might have a romance
going on but we've been friends for so
long should it happen
and then we consult ELISA week yes no
we're Alyssa and Jerry
do they have chemistry what's gonna
happen oh no and Lauren and Dan
nothing happens there they're just
friends okay Shawn Dozier yo Ryan
Kennedy's have a shout-out sure
okay Shawn Dozier I sound like a type of
drug doesn't it
yeah okay Shawn Dozier like I feel like
it would be like that sleeping he could
be like yeah it could be like a type of
on some of that doze
you want somebody that was here but
those ear [ __ ] I do you inject it
I would inject it feel like it would
work you ever have you ever impacted a
drug no no have you ever injected a job
I'm injected in many drugs into my
system god I'm drugged up right now
Carolyn LSD even then only with you in
saying heroin alone
I love heroin dude kay Sean Dozier if
you haven't done heroin yet try it
don't listen best time of your life
gives the word only
now we can Oh
here's how these two sleep oh they both
make this noise when they sleep it's not
that uncommon what are you guys framing
about are you in the same dream right
come on
anyway I Keyshawn Dozier yeah I mean if
you're a type of heroin you keep it up